vaccines work it's safe it's not
political it's medical we're honestly
tired of seeing unvaccinated people come
in sick and have to be admitted but it
is also true the doctors care for
everybody no matter how they got sick
what this is really about is the
politicization so here's the question
and it's a question that nobody on the
left has been willing to answer so the
left wants the right to answer how many
deaths are you willing to take for
freedom
and the answer on the right is some
right because this is true for virtually
all human activity
we all don't here's the thing human
beings don't tend to think about risk
level very often
we don't right if you thought about the
risk level of driving your car every day
and you were just every day in the media
if you get in your car you got a one in
one thousand chance of dying today
getting in your car if you thought about
that every single day you might not want
to get in your car maybe like i'm gonna
get an uber i'm gonna get on a bus right
but you don't think about it so it so in
your mind risk is binary there are
things that are risky and things that
are not risky it is not as though you
actually sit there and you calculate the
risks of all the things they're just the
things that are quote unquote risky and
the things that are quote unquote not
risky so for example skydiving you think
of this as a risky activity i think of
it as a risky activity the truth is
you're probably more like i think
significantly more likely to die in a
car accident than you are to die
skydiving but one immediately goes to
i'm jumping out of a plane that sounds
riskier than getting behind the wheel of
a car so one is risky and one is not
risky in your mind driving around every
day is a risk factor of zero in reality
your risk factor driving around is
significantly higher depending on your
age bracket and certainly post
vaccination than your risk of dying from
covid
okay this is
just statistically the reality post
vaccination there's no question you are
significantly more likely to die in a
car accident than you are to die from
covid 19 after you're vaccinated and you
see vaccinated people who have put
living normal life in the category of
very risky living without a mask in the
category of very risky
and so the question for those people is
okay so the question so when it comes to
freedom
we all recognize in in normal areas of
life sort of in the back of our mind we
recognize that there's a risk of death
to freedom right any time you go to a
ball game there could be a terrorist
attack anytime you go out driving you
could get in a car accident anytime you
walk out your front door there's a risk
of something bad happening to you and we
all accept that as part of normal life
and so the question is how much risk are
you willing to accept in order to
continue normal life and the answer is
post vaccination you should be living
your normal life
post vaccination you get you should we
should all get back to living our normal
life post vaccination because there is
no alternative but to do so
okay otherwise
these are your choices get back to
normal life post vaccination or spend
the rest of your life masking and
waiting for the government to tell you
what to do
that is those are your choices
for the left there's no limiting
principle for people who have become
coveted crazy there is no limiting
principle to this
for them i ask a question
what level of freedom are you willing to
give up to prevent
very small numbers of death
what level of freedom
in australia the answer is all of it
okay this should scare everybody in the
west in australia the answer is
literally all the freedom
australia is a country of some 25
million people
the the australian covet death rates day
on day are like three
australia has been having
about three deaths a day from coven
they are having
800 900 cases of delta because it turns
out you cannot just shield yourself
behind fortress ocean forever which is
what australia tried to do for a year
australia basically made it that you
could not travel into australia
they basically tried to have a plague
city right they were just going to cut
off all outside contact with the outside
world and then one person entered with
delta and now they have an explosion in
new cases
they bought by the way they did not
bother to get everybody vaccinated
because they were so confident in their
ability to shut out the outside world
that their vaccination rate in australia
remember america is terrible for our
vaccination right right we're the worst
we're just we're just awful it doesn't
matter that vast majority of adults in
the united states above the age of 18
like over 70 percent have had the
vaccine already in australia the number
of adults the percentage of adults who
have been vaccinated in australia is
about 25 about one quarter they have a
huge unvaccinated vulnerable population
so because of that australia has decided
they're going to crack down and when
they say they're going to crack down i
mean they are going to crack down so
here is a little bit of tape from nine
news in australia talking about the
measures they are taking this is full
authoritarian lockdown with no limiting
principle in sight
there's little sympathy for anyone
ignoring the health orders even this
group of teenagers caught partying after
dark at the bottom of the north bondi
cliffs
herded to higher ground by polar's
spotlight and speaker the eight boys
were placed in handcuffs and left to
explain a thousand dollar fine to mum
681 penalty infringement notices issued
in the last 24 hours more than 400 of
those notices were again for people
being outside of their home without a
reasonable excuse okay this is dystopian
insanity they've locked people in their
homes in a country of 25 million people
for three to four deaths a day
okay and they've locked them down
they're locking them down for weeks over
there
they outlawed protest by the way
in fact
we were told yesterday on the program by
a by a journalist from australia that
they have outlawed even saying things in
favor of protest in australia
because that would be promoting breaking
the law so what kind of tyranny are you
willing to undergo
in order to never get back to real life
and avoid all risk forever
and then you're going to have to ask
another question which is how much
pressure are you willing to bring on the
unvaccinated
in order to get them to vaccinate again
in order to protect their own lives
there's a story on msnbc that was making
the rounds yesterday
75 doctors claimed that they walked off
the job to protest the unvaccinated in
reality that's not really what was
happening
apparently what was actually happening
is they they exited the building to
encourage people to get vaccinated which
is fine right you wanna you wanna
encourage people to get vaccinated
that's fine msnbc covered it as though
these doctors were saying that they
would they did not want to care for the
unvaccinated
okay here is a little bit of the tape
from msnbc
as i step out here i can see they're all
standing here white jackets some coming
off of their shifts your thoughts about
why it's gotten to this point that
people are gathered like this we feel
that people think it's political and
it's not it's medical i have all my
colleagues behind me and we're all here
as physicians to say one message
vaccines work it's safe it's not
political it's medical and we're very
passionate about it because we're
honestly tired of seeing unvaccinated
people come in sick and have to be
admitted okay so the way that the left
covered this is their suggestion was
that the doctors were refusing to care
for the unvaccinated and there is a lot
of talk in the media about how we should
be triaging in favor of the vaccinated
over the unvaccinated as opposed to
triaging based on who's most likely to
survive in a crisis scenario which is
usually how you triage right you
actually look at the health conditions
of the people underlying is it an 85
year old with with terminal cancer or is
it a 30 year old who is who's generally
healthy but has the disease and now can
be triaged
right the the
the attempt here
is to suggest that people don't deserve
medical care if they're unvaccinated now
i've said that if you're unvaccinated
that is on you but it is also true that
doctors care for everybody no matter how
they got sick right if somebody wheels a
person into the er who is shot in a in a
gang duel in a gang in a bout of gang
violence the doctors don't say well you
know they kind of brought it on himself
they were in a sort of gang violence
scenario i guess i'm not caring for this
but that's not what doctors do if
somebody comes in and they're morbidly
obese and they've been told by their
doctor for literally their entire life
that they need to start eating healthy
and lose weight and now they have heart
disease the doctor isn't like well i did
tell you you shouldn't do that right
nobody that is not how medicine is
practiced
and i i find it rather dystopian and
scary that there are people on the left
who are saying this sort of stuff people
on the left are saying this they're
saying if you're unvaccinated and you
come into the hospital the hospital
shouldn't treat you i'm amused to see
however many people on the left say
things like if you come into the
hospital unvaccinated you should be
responsible for your own medical bills
that i'm in favor for i'm in favor of
that except not not with regard to
vaccination and not vaccination i'm in
favor of that for everything we call
that a privatized medical health care
system right in which you are
responsible for your own health
okay but
again what this is really about is the
politicization i'm amazed to watch
people on the left say that the right is
politicizing this
no when you have dr fauci saying it
doesn't matter what mask you wear you
just need to mask up post vaccination
everywhere and when you have joe biden
saying you need to mask your kids every
time they leave the house when you have
joe biden saying your business should
tell people that they cannot work for
you if they are unvaccinated
who's making that political
and what's the real goal the real goal
of course is to distract from the giant
the reason we're doing that this week
right now the reason we've upped the
ante is not because the stats show that
we should up the ante this week as
opposed to like three or four weeks ago
the reason that we are doing this right
now is because joe biden needs to
redirect away from the gigantic failure
we are currently experiencing in
afghanistan and the crisis that is
likely to materialize over the course of
the next week
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content